[Narrator] The answer for this one may be a little surprising.
The answer is 3, here's why: the first statement creates the list
with the elements 1, 2, and P refers to that list.
The second statement creates the list with the elements 3, 4
and assigns that to the variable Q:
The third statement appends a new element on the list P.
That element is the list with 2 elements,
but what actually happens is not adding 2 elements to P.
What happens with append is we're just appending 1 new element.
That element happens to be a list.
The way this looks is we have a new element in P.
The value of that element is actually the list object that Q refers to.
That's why the length of P is 3.
Let's try this in the Python interpreter.
Here we see the list that's created.
We can see that the length of that list is 3.
What do you think will happen if we try an assignment like this?
We're replacing the element at position 1 of Q with the value 5.
Does that change the value of P?
It does, and if you remember the picture we drew,
it's not surprising that it does.
Remember that the object we had created, the third element of P,
is actually a reference to this object containing the elements 3, 4,
which is the same list object that Q references.
When we change the value in position 1 of Q
that also changes the value of P.